[Applauso]
sarò ad internet
oggi è tristissimo richiesta non proprio
che la scatola o non distruggere quella
scatola può rompere le scatole solvay
per vedere che detta altissima una
congiura abbastanza aden
però aggiunge i 15.000 live della
vittima tra vitale e saranno nessun
contenitore distrutte e ridare la gente
raccordo vittima ea metterne uno alla
volta
in una di queste tre scatole e io ogni
volta con un martello
dovrò distruggere un pescatore viene
questo è di jobs è presissimo oggi si
sta bene commenti quali abbraccia le
potete vedere possibilmente in cui non
veniva visto come evitare la vittima
presentare nei commenti e niente è il
primo oggetto nel salvadanaio mimmo de
rita
qui 20 a me tantissimo e poi
potenzieranno che ha quindi si
interrompe subito della disney comprato
dottore dove volumi ricorda prime ma ce
n'è
allora una loro abbiamo finalmente
[Musica]
sentirsi ok zio allora tra l'altro se
lui mette quando mentre l'oggetto io
penso che non sento perché sempre rumore
quindi mi metterò a cantare una
canzoncina non devi toccare vendendo
l'edizione latte o poi potrebbe spaccare
il tau box
martin è pesantissimo partiamo dal
centro di una domanda convinto al 100
della scatola così si romperà a vado
avanti
e stato terribile
mamma mia accettate entro valori grazie
anche al centro no si no 133 ceramica
anche quello che sono
compito non facile le cose migliori
proprio reti belle tutte quelle disney
[Musica]
ed è pronta a cc con parma nella scatola
di mente
secondo me non l'ha rimesso dove ho
colpito prima
conoscendoti le rime stato rimesso primo
perché penso che non andrà mai a colpire
che sopprime ma andrea poi credo che ho
colpito prima si è capito mio
ragionamento io non l'ho capito
[Applauso]
[Musica]
siamo al massimo a staccarsi da queste
cose materiali tutela della pesca
adesso rischia qualcosa oppure no
fatemelo sapere se era così sarà più
contenuto st volo delta in questo sosta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi aspetto che è un problema o un
problema tecnico
io ho dovuto spostare alla camera la
notizia mi hanno detto che abbiamo un
[Musica]
quando vuoi pronti
quale allora io spero nel fatto che
anche se a colpisco non si rompano
proprio perché non è inizierà amica di
plastica forse potresti a carlo è un
grande pezzo non offre favoriti
allora non mi sposto profonda nero
viaggia si sa la verità
non minuti marciare anche questo questo
il computer il tuo delle classiche la
corda e dopo vi ricordate l'alberello no
dai non tremano in cristallo e monza che
cristo ha costruito un batterio alla 39
st non costruisce nei cristalli
insomma la far crescere ancora vedo che
anche questi giorni capita non si rompa
anche se molto fragile si sbracciano
becco cadrà molto crystal e con buffet
[Musica]
hai fatto no
ok adatti a tale mole pesa allora
secondo me
secondo me come piccolo non l'hai visto
nelle scatole grandi ma lei messo cioè
un effetto leggermente più grossa
scatola e queste sono leggermente più
come va bene se con questo al centro
[Musica]
vera
per questo da distruggere e salvo
prossimo oggetto
questo è uno slide lo sai che ho fatto
insieme tra l'altro non ancora nel mezzo
poi certo c'è si spacca e 1.014 tu io
l'ho scelto questo perchè era di sterne
non piace l'italia centrerà la trigger
di trucco ha un sensore da almeno sarei
contenta di romperlo a parte che quello
che abbiamo fatto assieme re la
challenge di tricolore di collateral
coordinato punto stato attendendo non
piace quindi una buona scusa per
romperla
mi chiamo stato ascoltato così almeno se
dai un supporto
[Musica]
ok ci sei tanto per un primo battello
sulle scatole
per l'estate quest'anno coprendo pronte
ha perso il pazzo diritto in giro altra
parte è meglio così quando davvero
questa dopo di tempo che non la trovo
[Musica]
aiuto se non vengo mi faccio male non
fanno vedere scatola bravi e molto male
innanzitutto desiano come diventa
comincia un po di attivatore quella che
belle con i clijsters che bernheim
[Musica]
diverte che nella challenge mentre
colori avete buttato l'italia va detto
che mi chiama lui o lei o di pagare la
cena era bello ma perché allora perché
non lo era più bello zero prossimo detto
prossimo c'è sicuramente stavo pensando
di fare una sorpresa non te lo dico
vuole del prossimo oggetto è un oggetto
sorpreso cosa avete il mio macbook il
computer non ci mette al computer basta
che mi assicuri che qualcosa che non è
certo che e qualcosa sicuramente sarà
qualcosa cui tiene tanto a un piatto di
parole per i mandarini ficarazzi mosè
cielo
però non è un ascoltato anche posso
assicurare che era una cosa e noi siamo
salutati non lo so di mano valore
affettivo allora monetario ha
sicuramente una cosa che cosa poco
sicuro ma qui non devo troppo che è
essenziale è troppo sicuramente una cosa
che ci viene fermato da una 10h ci tieni
un bel set 8 però avuto maremoto qua
fatto così tornano le cose al di là 10
euro dice sistema inizia européens pace
valore affettivo sottozona che sono
tutte le mie lettere di insieme la più
pura metterà da buster mediati andrai
mai quella bene la vecchia parola di
euro un po di più di più e anche qui
vale che si erano non è compiuto ed ecco
che poi dopo mandarmi in tale video
spesa va bene antigone ha detto cafiero
tirando sulle scatole
[Musica]
[Risate]
ci sono secondo esposto anche se mi ha
detto che vale poco
non solo fatto di non sapere che cos'è
che potrebbe essere qualsiasi cosa a me
mi fa pensare che sia qualcosa di
primark della disney che mi piazzetta
[Musica]
ministro una cosa che materia lei è una
cosa che si nota facilmente certo qui
perché molti mentre non trovano più
questo è l'ultimo oggetto non è visto
che un partito la scatola nera ha così
toccato un podestà scopo questo mi
insospettisce c'è sicuramente una logica
del perché impartito le scatole trance
linee su quella grande alla centro
quindi forse voi se io lo dico che è un
po aperta ma non sto guardando non si
vede ma ti ricorderò sempre scambiate
questa prima stava qua
e questa cosa per farsi questa non è
cambiata e quindi non c'è niente come me
lo dite le stava cambiare questa fusione
e lanteri che mi batte a mille la
tranquillo detto questo nuovo ma che
cosa ho deciso alla ieri con questa
perché non l'hai spostata si scherzava
ma è uguale è fatto molto molto bella ci
vediamo questo negli anni di vita sapevo
che si vuole anche dire il vero anche i
bottoni sembra tutto vero però non ti ho
fatto il pezzo di celano dietro non
sottomettiamo stime che non lo spaccato
tanto
perché un pezzo di certo sono dietro
vero però in realtà so per certo il mio
telefono quad a questo identico apre
bianco così immagini siccome la pratica
le non aveva una memoria è un po c'è
conta che venga portali occhiali a
prenderlo prendevi quello vero senso
delle cose l'astro forti comando mi
raccomando fate online ipotizzeranno in
cui esso corriere ad offrire sono potata
unità vogliamo un altro fatto dall'unità
le preghiere sa sempre cosa economiche
che costano pochi soldi il matrimonio
come te le scarpe nuove che ti ha
regalato perché mi sembra su questo
video che è piaciuto se volete che l'ha
vinta la prossima vittima sia vitale o
ios e divertiti a vedermi soffrire o se
volete vedere suppliche lui facciamo la
pizza ciarla non ci piace che la vera
devi far tornare lì dobbiamo scriverla
pizzo challenge sdraiati che sono auto
marco de melo sociale di questa dobbiamo
farla quindi qualcosa in cui dovesse
aprire tanto rimettervi nei commenti
tutto qua quattro cartellini di cui
potete cliccare per vedere le nostre
prossime challenge le nostre altre falle
isolate video divertenti che casa scuola
anche presente a mediare
ciao
[Musica]